this is the new most expensive iPhone in
the world it's gonna go for 616
000 so this is called the caviar Diamond
snowflake there's only three of them in
the world and it's an iPhone 14 pro Max
basically absolutely decked out with a
custom back covered in 18 karat white
gold and 570 diamonds it's so expensive
that there's an unboxing experience for
the key to the unboxing experience this
phone is absurdly gaudy it's double the
thickness of a normal phone and what
doesn't really come through on video is
how heavy it is this phone with now
stones on the back is over a pound it
weighs more than an iPad and if all that
sounds ridiculous I lied because this is
actually the one they sent to the studio
is just the Crystal Edition so this is
one of 20 and it's only 25 000 so look
out budget phone of the year if you
already really don't want to drop your
phone but I guess now for stupidly rich
people you really don't want to drop
your phone because